i liked
what i was doing i liked working
but little did i think
it would go this far
katherine johnson catherine g johnson
catherine
johnson
[Applause]
liftoff the clock has started
mathematics is the basis of the whole
thing
[Music]
you graduated from high school at 14
college at 18. everybody knew you had a
big old brain on you by that time
i didn't know but you didn't know it man
you're either right or you're wrong that
i liked about it
she always loved numbers the professor
said
i think you'd make a good math
researcher she said well what's that
he said well that's for you to find out
that was her dream catherine johnson
found her way to hampton virginia
and there is nasa
nasa was hiring black mathematicians
[Music]
just opened it up to women
i was finally going to find out what a
research mathematician did
those women took a seat and that changed
our country
catherine johnson was a trailblazer she
became what was known then as a
as a computer or a calculator or human
computer
courage is just one of many words that
describe this woman
being the first woman in the room of all
white men in a time when that was not
popular
the courage to even walk in that room
with your head held high i don't think
many people could do that
[Music]
when i think about my experiences and
those with kathryn johnson
i am completely in on she overcame
so much more over prejudice so many more
challenges than i was ever faced with
in 1957 when the russians launched the
sputnik satellite
the space race then became her job
calculating trajectories for mercury
missions
and project apollo catherine johnson was
so good at what she did
they needed her as an engineer
when they had briefings i asked
permission to go
and they said well the girls don't
usually go and i said well
is there a law i began attending the
briefings
and gradually i did more
the eagle has landed when they were
leaving the moon
going back that was the part that i
worried about
[Music]
they should be exactly correct on that
and i'm sitting there hoping i'm right
too
[Music]
without mathematicians those great
moments wouldn't have happened
[Music]
in her 33 years at nasa catherine was a
pioneer
who broke the barriers of race and
gender
everyone can excel in math and science
and reach for the stars
catherine often remarked that even
though there were medals and awards and
so many things that she received and
honors
her favorite thing to receive wear
letters from children
catherine johnson has taught me not to
let anyone bring me down
and that women are capable of doing
anything they want to do
catherine johnson has taught me to
believe in myself
and my capabilities kathryn johnson was
an amazing
african-american female mathematician
who changed the world
because of catherine and nasa we've
embraced that diversity of thought only
improves our capacity to make change
both in outer space and here on earth
now
younger versions of myself don't have to
wait until they're an adult to finally
hear about her to let her be a role
model in their lives today
my problem was to answer questions
and i did that to the best of my ability
at all times
and it was a joy
[Music]
[Music]
you